hypocrisy is only made possible by the
existence of ideals okay there's a
reason we can't call a big part of my
speech just now was about the CCP say
what you will about the Chinese
Communist party you can never call them
Hypocrites because in order to be a
hypocrite you had to have ideals in the
first place you can call Thomas
Jefferson a hypocrite because he had
ideals and so he's a reminder of not
only the existence of ideals but the
fact that we as human beings are flawed
deeply flawed there will be people 250
years from now that look back at us
today and say weren't they Hypocrites we
just don't know what basis they're going
to have for saying it but it's
definitely going to happen the La Roche
Focus said that hypocrisy is the tribute
Vice pays to Virtue that's exactly right
you said it better than I did you know
well at least La rochuko did I don't use
speechwriters but if I did you know you
know you know this is a few years from
now if I'm successful in the white house
maybe we got to talk